[Musique]
nous voilà aujourd'hui en république
dominicaine en continu le trip je vous a
emmené depuis quelques jours avec moi
dans les bagages je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui d'un smartphone
venez voir c'est celui là un smartphone
résistants une craint rien et justement
c'est ce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui c'est
le armor 3 du lait phone mais juste
avant je vous montrer mon nouveau sac
que j'utilise pour voyager c'est pas du
tout une vidéo spawn souvent je sais pas
payer pour en parler mais je trouve
franchement hyper intéressant et ça
c'est cool pour tous les voyageurs et je
pense que ça peut être une bonne astuce
c'est un sac de chez targus et jusqu'à
il n'y a pas très longtemps j'utilisais
un sac de herschel super beau très
classe mais pas hyper pratique parce
qu'une seule dans une grande poche tout
était au fond pour trouver ce n'est pas
très pratique et ça franchement c'est
super cool vous montrait très rapidement
ce qui est vraiment cool d'ansac bon
hormis le fait que ce soit un sac à dos
déjà il ya une protection en arrière une
poche pour mettre tous vos papiers
convoyage et comme ça vous n'avez pas
risques vous faire tirer quoi que ce
soit franchement c'est confort ça c'est
cool
et surtout il ya une multitude de poche
là moi je range mon oeuvre mon petit
disque dur mon lecteur car dessous mais
batterie mes cartes et ça vous pouvez
venir l'arraché à la wii directement
mais tout vote matos dessus ce qui fait
que vous le prenez vous le sortez ça
vous fait un petit bureau vous
prenez-vous leur peser tac tac tac ça
marche bon je ne fais pas comme ça mais
ça c'est une utilité je trouve vraiment
cool ici c'est pareil une petite poche
pour angers des conneries et la grand
poste où je peux tout ranger là j'ai mon
casque de sony j'ai mon appareil photo
j'ai mon casque jet de la lecture et
surtout dans les sacs targus qui coule
c'est que là je peux ranger mon macbook
pro 15 pouces qui est juste là et ici
clou du spectacle
je mets mes lunettes de soleil qui sont
forcément avec moi puisqu'il fait super
beau il fait super chaud
en plus de ça ici j'ai eu une prise en
usb que je vais retrouver à l'intérieur
avec le câble ici dans la grande poste à
l'intérieur ce qui fait que si je le
branche est quelque chose en usb là et
hop à flower en extérieur sans
m'embêtait c'est pas pratique
et là j'ai une autre poche où je range
mon petit chargeur franchement c'est
hyper pratique je voulais faire une
petite aparté dessus parce que pour moi
enfin qui voyage beaucoup je sais pas si
c'est votre cas pour tous les voyageurs
ce truc là et franchement hyper pratique
bon c'est pas un sac qui coûte une
fortune
raconter on est aux alentours des 200
euros voire un petit peu moins cher
c'est pas un truc de ouf mais je vous
mets un lien en matière d'inscription
s'est toutefois ça vous intéresse
parlons maintenant justement de larmor
3-2 et phone qui manque c'est dans la
poche
il est là il est beau il échoue en
rangeant après la boîte j'aime bien
alors bon ça c'est pas une grosse grosse
bête de compet mais c'est quand même
cool il pourquoi êtes vous avez plein de
choses voilà comment les stars c'est pas
le facto sans trop gentilles et non ici
ici qu'est ce qu'on à carde de garde si
manuel d'utilisation cinq grands
classiques le câble de recharge
différents adaptateurs ça c'est cool ça
c'est pour le tenir directement à la
main adaptateur usb type c'est vers usb
un adaptateur usb type sévère micro usb
et avec ça vous allez venir des montées
pour votre tiroir de cartes sim je vous
montrais et si votre blog de recharge
rapide parce que forcément il faut de la
recharge rapide parce qu'à l'intérieur
de ce smartphone vous avez une batterie
de 10000 millions paire eur et là sous
le cache
vous avez vos deux cartes sim qui vont
venir se loger juste la cime un sim 2 et
là une carte micro sd pour venir
rajouter de la mémoire
ça c'est franchement cool
[Musique]
je vous le donne dans le mille ce
smartphone est fait pour l'outdoor vous
aurez vu l'épaisseur du truc vous en
douterez et sa smart phones qui fait
pour toutes les personnes qui veulent
aller faire de la randonnée de la balade
qui part vraiment en expédition assez
longtemps et qui ont besoin d'un truc
vraiment hyper résistant et le gros gros
gros gros gros point fort de smartphones
c'est très clairement sa très grosse
batterie de 10000 milliampères heures
pour la coucher il vous en faudra alors
l'idée c'est que lorsque vous partez en
vadrouille si vous êtes bloqué s'il ya
un imprévu s'il ya quoi que ce soit au
moins vous pouvez compter sur votre
smartphone vous avez une très grosse
batterie derrière vous attendez pas à
voir des performances de fou c'est
derrière un médiathèque saint élie au p
23 c'est pas hyper puissant c'est pas un
truc de fou là dessus ce qu'on va
vraiment venir rechercher c'est un
smartphone qui va durer c'est un
smartphone avec de l'autonomie de la
robustesse vous pouvez mettre dans l'eau
sans aucun problème il craint pas les
chocs
il est résistant ça franchement c'est un
excellent atout
[Musique]
le design n'est pas complètement ouf
mais ça marche il faut aimer les oranje
il faut aimer le noir après ça
fonctionne vous avez une très belle
symétrie sur l'avant ça me fait penser
un petit peu rauque phone d'asus ce côté
symétrie je sais pas pourquoi vous avez
sur le côté un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui est directement intégrée
pour positionner votre pouce de sucer
les verrouille tout de suite c'est
franchement hyper hyper pratique sur le
côté vous avez un bouton pour l'allumer
pour l'éteindre et si le capteur
d'empreintes digitales il voulut marque
schott franc sur le côté en dessous là
vous avez up votre petit usb type c'est
qu'il faut bien fermer pour bien
conserver
l'étanchéité la ce a voulu marquer
également waterproof le bouton ptt ce
n'est pas l'ancien nom de la poste c'est
un bouton pour l'utiliser en mode talkie
walkie talkie walkie faisait pouvoir
bien branché ici votre antenne vous
dévissé vous venez mettre votre antenne
à l'antenne moi je n'ai pas trouvé dans
la boîte donc bon je l'ait pas j'espère
a priori elle n'est pas livrée avec ici
bouton de volume et s'avoue lui marque
aussi certifié ip 68 et là à l'arrière
vous avez la partie comme je le montre
et à l'heure pour dire à ses rivaux de
cartes sim et votre carte mémoire
ici vous avez une caméra de 21
mégapixels et à l'avant une toute petite
caméra ici cachée de 13 mégapixels
la luminosité est franchement ok là je
les pousser à fond pour voir qu'on est
en pleine journée qu'on est sous le
soleil du mois de février en république
dominicaine ça va franchement bien vous
avez une diagonale de 5,7 pouces c'est
une révolution et fhd plus de 1160 par
1080 un ratio 18/9 c'est du lcd mais
franchement ça marche très bien
qualité photo vidéo c'est pas mal à
l'arrière n'allez pas chercher des
photos nuit là dessus c'est pas du tout
un smartphone qui est fait pour ça par
contre pour les photos en plein jour
avec une bonne lumière franchement vous
serez pas déçus c'est pas un capteur de
fou mais ça fait le job
à l'avant la 13 mégapixels est un peu
light c'est un peu limite mais bon de
toute façon est un smartphone comme ça
très clairement vous n'allez pas
chercher à faire des selphy dans la
partie édition photo vous avez la partie
vidéo où vous allez pouvoir venir
choisir bon mode scène vous allez
pouvoir venir et choisir parce que là
dessus il n'ya pas d'intelligence
artificielle qualité de la vidéo volonté
jusqu'en 1080p uniquement ici il n'ya
pas grand chose
image panoramique et c'est tout alors au
niveau de l'image hdr pages d r flash et
ensuite au niveau des paramètres vous
pouvez venir faire des photos
jusqu'en 21 méga pixels format 16/9 silo
4/3 voyez c'est pas folichon point qui
est sympa là dessus vous avez du nfc
notamment pour les paiements
dématérialisés alors je sais pas si vous
l'utilisez mais en tout cas c'est plutôt
pas mal que ce soit là dedans vous avez
4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
extensible mais très clairement c'est
pas ce que vous en pensez mais on va pas
acheter ce smartphone pour chercher de
la performance
ce qu'on cherche là dessus c'est un
outil pratique passe-partout résistant
avec une grosse grosse grosse grosse
batterie et pour moi là dessus très
clairement le téléphone armour iii
remplit parfaitement sa mission après il
tourne sur un android 8.1 oreo après y'a
des trucs qui sont pas mal notamment
toolbox que vous allez trouver tout en
bas ici vous allez pouvoir mesurer le
son ambiant
alors ici il ya une grosse ventilation
est avec moi qui parle à côté on se
retrouve tout de suite dans un
environnement qui assez calme un
environnement bruyant chaplin bruit mais
quand même vous allez avoir ensuite une
boussole forcément un grand classique un
niveau ok cool pour venir apposer votre
tableau au mur qu'ils soient bien droit
ça c'est assez pratique vous allez
pouvoir mesurer votre fréquence de
rythme cardiaque
ça balance de la lumière directement sur
votre doigt raffault pas bougé 87
j'y crois pas trop je suis franchement
assez cool tout de suite bon ce que vous
avez différents outils vous avez une
loupe mon appareil photo et humide faut
qu'il sèche une équerre mesurer la
pression mais c'est quand même assez
surprenant qu'il la flotte qui pu
rentrer là dedans donc ça me fait de
doute un petit peu de l'étanchéité de
l'appareil ça bon voilà alors vous avez
qu'une diffusion d' alerte pour savoir
quelles sont les urgences qui ont été
émises dans votre région
alerte enlèvement menace extrême menace
grave bon ça ça peut être intéressant et
dans les paramètres auxiliaires
intelligent vous allez pouvoir par
exemple naviguer avec plusieurs doigts
pour faire des captures d'écran brûler
les trucs on a l'impression que ce n'est
pas complètement fini traduire capture
on sait pas trop faire une capture 2 on
sait pas trop sinon vous avez de
l'optimisation de votre batterie pour
voir déjà que la batterie est
franchement énorme vous plaît encore
plus venir l'optimiser ça c'est assez
cool ya pas mal de petites options
c'est assez intéressant la surcouche moi
elle me dérange pas par contre après le
poids est assez énorme c'est à vous
voyez il est résistant sa smart phones
qui pèse son poids c'est un smartphone
qui est très épais c'est pas un
smartphone
qui se glisse discrètement dans votre
poche mais c'est pas du tout son adn
mais surtout été le plus important est
que ce smartphone c'est qu'une
certification ip68 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière vous pouvez l'immerger
pendant une demi heure vous êtes
tranquille alors vous n'allez pas faire
de la plongée sous marine avec mais s'il
rencontre de l'eau s'ils tombent dans
l'eau douce même dans l'eau d'une
piscine vous n'aurez pas de souci ça
c'est franchement cool et vos amis
certification ip67 cas certification
militaire il peut prendre des chocs ne
peut tomber il peut faire des chutes
ça va il est résistant vous amuser le
pas le mettre sous entend qu mais pour
sa fonction outdoor ça va vous êtes
tranquille
[Musique]
on
maintenant ce que je regrette avec ce
smartphone c'est que lorsque vous lancez
la caméra vous faites une vidéo vous
vous mettez dans l'eau eh ben ça marche
absolument pas et ça c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'il n'est pas possible
de verrouiller l'écran comme vous pouvez
le faire notamment être le cros cole le
tracker x4 ça pour moi c'est un peu
dommage parce que vu que c'est un
smartphone qui ne craint pas l'eau vent
tuellement vous pouvez vous dire par
extension je peux le mettre dans l'eau
je peux me replonger avec en tout cas
aller faire des petites vidéos des
petites photos sous l'eau et pour le
coup c'est pas possible
et ça franchement ça hyper dommage parce
que pour moi ça serait une super
fonctionnalités en plus de se dire
j'appuie sur un bouton je verrouille
l'écran ça serait bien et pour le coup
vous pouvez pas faire ni de photos sous
l'eau ni de vidéo seul au secteur
[Musique]
bien évidemment vous avez verre corning
gorilla glass 5 dessus avec le
smartphone résistance à te paraît la
moindre des choses pas mal par les
tranchées que sur les photos que j'ai
trouvé du lait phone on le voit le
smartphone quelqu'un là dans la main
plomb sous l'eau avec se prend en photo
avec la caméra de saïfi mais moi j'ai
très clairement pas trouvé je sais pas
vous de votre côté
est ce que vous le connaissez ce
smartphone d'ailleurs les téléphones
quand vous allez regarder cette vidéo
dites moi comment tu fais pour
verrouiller l'écran lorsqu'on utilise la
caméra parce que vraiment j'ai pas du
tout trouvé ça me paraît pas du tout
intuitif
à titre d'info je vous parlais du mouton
ptt tout à l'heure ça veut dire
push-to-talk donc c'est vraiment une
fonction talkie walkie
si vous voulez aller à la chasse il
voulait aller vous pas une nature pas
mon père pouvait faire ça marche ces
pratiques en termes de poids il fait 3
164 g c'est un mastodonte illettrés
l'eau il est assez épais mais bon voilà
on peut pas tout avoir sur notre équipe
est résistant solide il faut passer par
là et s'il vous intéresse pour la
modique somme de 329 euros 99
il peut être avoue d'ailleurs si ça vous
botte je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans
la description
je sais pas vous c'est un truc qui peut
vous intéresser ses smartphones
résistants est-ce que vous partez
souvent faire des traits qu'est-ce que
vous partez souvent en extérieur est ce
que vous chassez est-ce que vous pêchez
est ce que c'est un produit qui pourrait
vous tentez comment vous le trouvez par
rapport à ce qu'on peut voir la
concurrence
comment vous trouvez son prix va vous
invite à marquer tout ça en bas en
commentaire et si vous avez des
questions faites vous plaisir
bon pour l'instant je retourne profiter
un peu intime des jouets de la
république dominicaine je voulais pas
vous avez vu avec vous même en vacances
je pense à vous je publie du contenu
donc ça c'est cool bon je vous embrasse
d'ici là amusez vous bien
moi je retourne ciao
non